television helps politicians reach
bigger audiences it's why many back the
idea of leaders debates in general
elections Sky News is campaigning for an
independent body to oversee and organize
the debates and with labour pushing for
a snap election their support among
party members for an independent debates
commission I think it's something that
really should be sorted out because
we've had people arguing about it for
the last two elections and I think
definitely this time it should be
organized and properly attended by the
right people I think able to talk to
each other directly make the sort of
criticisms of each other's positions
that make those in front of the wider
public if there's no televised debate
the message come up which Vortice labor
in the Lib Dems are backing the idea
including the shadow business secretary
Rebecca long Bailey I think it's
interesting the point about the
Independent Commission because many of
our members you know would argue that
certain you know outlets would you know
favor one particular party or another so
it's important to make sure that these
leadership debates are fair and it's a
good opportunity for you know people
across Britain to hear about the
policies from particular parties without
the spin you know without the rhetoric
today the Sky News debate petition goes
live voters can sign online and support
the setting up of an independent
commission I think there's a real
enthusiasm for having debates I think
the danger is complacency yes of course
they should happen people think so
why wouldn't they happen and the fact
that matter is only if this can be moved
forward and certainly the petition is
one way of doing that will it actually
come about that the arrangements are in
place in time for debates of the next
election
the first televised leaders debate was
in 2010 with enough support they could
easily be a feature of all future
general elections floribunda Sky News
live report